we begin with this this morning the
number of people killed by Guatemala's
devastating volcanic eruption is rising
sharply the government says at least 69
people have been killed and an unknown
number are missing and believed to be
buried in the ash the volcan de fuego or
volcano of fire erupted on Sunday the
explosion filled the air with a dark mix
of ash rock and gas lava gushed down the
sides of the volcano as well it's it's
about 30 miles from the capital
Guatemala City home to about 3 million
people Manuel Bojorquez ez in the side
one of the restricted areas in El Rodeo
Manuel good morning good morning
hundreds of rescue workers are still
trying to reach areas remote areas
around the volcano that have become
impassable because of things like this
this is a mound of ash and you can see
in this village it goes as high as the
street signs and in some areas the
ground is still so hot that it can melt
the soles of your shoes from above the
once densely vegetated area surrounding
the volcano is now coated in thick grey
ash a day after the eruption much of the
charter rain was still too hot in some
places for rescuers to search for
survivors in areas that are reachable
rescue teams were protective masks and
use construction equipment to navigate
the dangerous conditions babies and
children killed during the eruption are
wrapped in blankets and taken to a
temporary morgue to be identified one
rescuer miraculously saved this baby
buried for nearly a day crews worked by
land and air to save stranded people in
towns close to the volcano on Monday
Guatemalan President Jimmy Morales
traveled to a hard-hit area were a woman
begged him for help mr. president my
family is missing she said all of my
brothers my mother all my family are
there more than 20 have disappeared
Sunday's violent eruption left many
residents with just minutes to try to
escape
government officials held off for hours
on issuing a warning because they
believed the threat was diminishing
before the blast
thousands of people are staying in
shelters as they wait for word about
their love to
we were just allowed into this one
shelter here it's set up in a gymnasium
and you can see where they're putting
down their cots for the night there are
men women children we've even seen pets
here these are all people displaced by
the volcano do you know people who are
missing or I don't know their names she
said but I know their faces and they're
not here just behind me are some of the
homes that are now half buried in ash
now even though the eruption has stopped
people here are not out of the woods
there is rain in the forecast that could
hamper rescue efforts and that rain
could also mix with all this ash and
create a concrete-like substance that
could further damage infrastructure here
well thank you very much Manuel
Bojorquez